not a game of life it's about as
offensive as a bowl of jell-o but the
original one from a hundred years
earlier he had squares like this the
first scheme of life wasn't just a game
it was a form of moral instruction and
it says something about how a society
thinks life should be lived and and now
[Music]
in a way the game of life started when
this chin disappeared Milton Bradley was
a young lithographer basically a printer
in Massachusetts when he made a thousand
prints of this man running for president
in 1860 when Abraham Lincoln grew a
beard those prints were worthless so
Bradley had to pivot
he took his printing skills and let them
loose on a young medium boardgames the
checkered game of life was his first
game and it became a hit players started
at infancy they spun a teetotum this
thing to determine options for their
move you had control to choose your move
once you spun the goal was to hit a
hundred points through five point
milestones like college and Congress or
big ones like 50 points for old age the
games patent shows that Milton Bradley's
life was more than just a social game it
was about great moral principles
Elizabeth Peabody founded the first
English kindergarten in the United
States in 1860 Milton Bradley published
this portrait of her well after his
Lincoln failure he also volunteered to
teach his own daughter's kindergarten
class in Springfield Massachusetts after
the success of life and he used his
business Milton Bradley and company to
publish games and educational tools
including more than 40 books about the
new kindergarten curriculum they made a
wide variety of learning tools from
educational puzzles to influential color
wheels education became Bradley's
passion and the original game of life
predicted that it was a way to teach the
chequered journey of life to children
and adults that weird spinner the
teetotum that was originally to avoid
cards and dice because they were
associated with gambling the location of
each spot also taught a lesson
old age was surrounded by many
difficulties poverty lies near the
cradle but passing through it didn't
hurt you in the beginning of the game
setbacks didn't earn you points but most
didn't kick you out of game either
[Music]
honesty led to happiness industry to
wealth and perseverance led to success
[Music]
I made 50,000 in the stock market today
why in 1960 lawn after Milton Bradley
died the company which by then was
mostly making games dug life from the
archives choosing it over a long list of
other games the company had once
published they adapted it to 1960s
America with a candy colored spinner and
stacks of cash and cars that could load
up a full family of baby boomers to
places like millionaire acres I went to
the poor farm I'm on millionaire acre
it's centered around paydays where the
value of winning a Nobel was the cash
prize that came with it
the winner was the person with the most
money today's versions are almost
identical with tweaks for different jobs
and hot brand integrations
that's why there was no more disgrace
but there also wasn't bravery or honor
or truth both versions are the game of
life which one should we play so when
game night is over you want your home to
be safe and that's where simply safe
comes in
they are the sponsor of this video
simply safes effective reliable home
security that will make sure your home
is safe it's easy to use easier than
this thing for sure you know how many
times I had to spin this thing for this
video so what makes simply safe protect
like a problem they've got 24/7
professional monitoring in police
dispatch that's three and a half times
faster so if there is a break-in
hopefully there's not a break-in but if
there is a break-in the police will be
called and they'll get there really
quick in their modern comprehensive that
means they've got interior and exterior
sensors to help keep track of things
experts like that three million people
like that a lot of people like that this
is not part of the odd this is for
sustenance so all this is about fifty
cents a day with no contracts there's
hardware - they've got the simply safe
lock which always makes sure that your
doors locked
simple as that a lot of break-ins happen
because the door is unlocked I know I've
done that I've run ten minutes back to
my house just to lock the door simply
safe takes care of that it also keeps
track of people and let's see grant
remote access so protect all those
beloved pink people in your life head
over to simply safecom slash box one
more time that's simply safe calm /vo X
simply safe doesn't directly impact our
editorial but their support makes videos
like this possible
[Music]